[Musique]
il
bonjour
tiens
[Musique]
la barre
il ya
eu en fait on fait des provisions notre
carte aussi on dort beaucoup parce qu'on
a passé la journée à marcher c'est
fatigant et on a le terrible actifs
par mois
[Musique]
les soirées sont très très bien on se
retrouve dans une salle un peu chauffé
donc c'est l'idéal s'il fait froid quand
même à l'extérieur et du coup ça permet
de se retrouver et puis bal et repas
c'est très bon pas du tout des paysans
jury des grains des brèdes comme a comme
à la maison quoi c'est super bon ça
ressemble mois son choix à la réunion
c'est très bon et très copieux ils
n'arrêtent pas de nous resservir et
toutes les cinq minutes mais c'est pas
trop des paysans là les pales palotie
[Musique]
ça se passe bien pour moi en tout cas
j'ai pas mal genou pas encore ça ça
passe vite et on a vu tous ses angles et
l'épée là on est en tee-shirt à sa danse
accueille un peu mais franchement là où
on sent qu'on redescend dans les bas
il fait chaud c'est oui j'ai pas de
combat tueur encore à part au dos mais
je pense c'est la fatigue
on est descendu très vite et
en buvant de l'eau mais ça se passe bien
je trouve que la descente et plus de jeu
que la montée est
on a plus tendance à glisser plus vite
tu es
flattant son meilleur nous
[Musique]